this is that Wow this place is huge
and maybe historical if anything okay
this is the entrance you kidding me this
looks like the entrance to a [ __ ]
prison not a hotel a prison in a tiara
oh my god
hello you are killing me please I can't
believe it it's so dark in here [ __ ]
dungeon hello solve this
oh yeah light that's crazy right maybe
it's best I turn around and [ __ ] off
home now hello
I feel like a goonie how do you guys how
are you
when I saw Gordon walk Ian I was very
scared because I knew that he was you
know trying to check into the hotel are
you running this place by yourself
yesterday you won today you are does
anyone work in reception me yeah are you
ready yes
see we're the server anyone for desk yes
my name is Mandy Mandy Gordon nice to
see you busy
yes papers indeed as you for Donna's
look up so maybe somebody else to check
the anything why do not feel like a
property I'm here hey come down and help
please feel like somebody that's here to
kind of cover the extra hours however I
do still get to listen to the complaints
though if you know Mandy but there's a
bulb missing there probably Jim likes to
take bulbs out of things so people can't
turn lights on so Jim likes to take
bulbs yes Jim likes to take bulb so take
the bulb out place it in that house
hello finally first name is van de banda
my wife's called Lucy oh rina rina nice
to see ya sister's owners if you don't
let me ask it I mean you look very young
to be running a hotel how old are you
I'm 27 right Amy I'm 32 Wow ladies and
you both run it together
yep so Mandy multitasks she does the
restaurant she's I'm actually the
general manager Wow general manager head
waitress and she looks like a bus ha I'm
not happy with her work it's really
difficult to find people who are
motivated to work and who wants to live
to live up to our standards what were
you doing you are in our best room the
melody of love to hear people shagging
in the next door no you must hear
something Wow holy mackerel is that mold
in there I wouldn't be surprised if it
were mold with the Wardrobe secondhand
my jacket wardrobe right over right
there I'm feeling really nervous right
now I know that the room was really
cluttered but I didn't realize it was
that bad well at least we have a light
bulb there's a man that goes around
nicking light bulbs out of the lamps
Mandy said that he doesn't turned on
some guy called Jim your father yeah mom
works in the business as well kind of
goes around and helps clean up after
people's mess oh they know news as well
so your parents bought you this place
when we saw this place I knew I had to
have it
so I found every single way possible to
convince my daddy no matter what I had
to do I just had to have it I personally
think they could have gotten it for
cheaper and they probably should have
what do you two do all day if mom and
dad are hands-on so what's your role I
do the bookkeeping I do the front desk
in the evening there was one day Gordon
I had to man the dining room and the
front desk
oh there was big sis I don't know where
you were I think you're in Minneapolis
or something
Minneapolis what are you doing back
there we just bought hotel I actually
needed some time to be alone and figure
things out so you take two weeks away
then what happened
she wasn't gone for two weeks she was
gone for three months three months she's
gone for three months I've been open for
six weeks I've heard your role what do
you do I'm seriously still confused what
my role is here I feel like I don't
understand
you don't know what your role is I feel
like a bunch of gas bubbles are just
flying all over molecules and atom
just everywhere right now did you stay
here before you bought it I stayed here
um how many times
what's once you stayed one [ __ ] night
overnight did you stay here no not here
in the other room down the hall show me
please this is actually my favorite room
[Music]
okay
the missus is so we stayed in this room
you stayed in this room this is even
worse than my room pee stains all over
the disgusting wallpaper holes in the
wall here why is this hotel in such a
state we have a lot of problems in the
south it's so hard Gordon to just repeat
myself the rudeness unprofessionalism
there is a chronic disease here of
complaining and bitching so the big
problem with the stuff yes pretty too
you're welcome for the jobs you're
welcome for the tips you're welcome
you're welcome